thank you
um good evening members
um I'd like to open this meeting of the
strategy and resources committee on
Thursday the 6th of October 2022 my name
is counselor Sue White and I'm the
chairman of this committee members with
stream this meeting live as well as
recording and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent to
being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak
I will then invite you at the
appropriate time please note that the
YouTube live stream sound recording is
dependent on the correct use of the
microphones therefore can I ask that
when invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and turn it off
when finished
please reference the page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
okay addendum item two apologies for
absence
um I've got apologies for councilor
siddle and Clans lafluka do we have any
others
no German that's all we have thank you
thank you Berner okay uh now we'll move
on to agenda item three which is the
minutes ah councilor fluke is here oh we
don't need we will cancel the apologies
welcome councilor Fluker
um the agenda item three is the minutes
it's recommended at the minutes of the
meeting held on the 14th of July 22
found on pages 5 to 14 are approved as a
true and accurate record I so move do I
have a second up thank you counselor
um
um do any members wish to raise a matter
yes of accuracy yes
um two or three points first of all on
page um
seven
item 165
the fifth bullet point
um
it says the council had to override the
cost of any under runs I think it should
be under right OverWatch isn't it
yeah thank you for that one
um
and
secondly item 166 power two
um
it should be commenced not commented
okay have they noted
and thirdly Madam chairman
um can I go back to that um
um previous minute one six five
um
yeah
I think it's
successful this was with the major
um height related bid
um this may provide an opportunity for
discussion with bar Jones has opposite
and may open other opportunities to fund
a more regular dredging program
um do you consider that is a cure
um record of that part of discussion I
can't find which page is that one on top
of page eight page eight the chalky the
last bullet point or the first bullet
point on page eight this one under the
terms of the luf trading mention of a
possibility from sources that would
enable regular dredging I I don't recall
that myself but I know demonstration was
discussed it was definitely discussed
um and I think it might have been a
possibility
um what we can do we can listen to the
recording and then um change it if it
needs to be changed yes I mean I may not
be recalling it properly but I really
wanted to see whether you thought it
probably was I think it was mentioned
but I'm not sure of the actual wording
of
um what we agreed
um but I will we'll look into that um
has any anybody else anybody else got
anything to raise
can we agree those by ascent
thank you okay
um right moving on to agenda item four
um Declarations of Interest
do we have any
councilor again thank you chair I just
um declare a
um interest in being a previous barge
owner because there's warfage on the
fees and charges
um schedule tonight I'm no longer an
owner I haven't had any correspondence
with the final Jonas for a while but I
feel I should disclose that okay thank
you and councilor stem
that's the channel
thank you very much chairman
um regarding a gender item
I can't see it now number 11.
um I believe I'm declaring the right
interest of Mr crouch on this
registerable interest because I'm a
trustee of an arms house charity now
there's no specific mention of that
charity and that report
um does refer to housing associations
won't even on the flow chart doesn't
mention armed houses but on a certain
page it does mention about housing
associations and arm houses so I do
believe I can stay for that item Madam
Jim yes however a gender item number 14
again
same type of thing regarding being a
register of interest in terms of the
arms house charity in the past there has
been through a fund Community we're
involved in community-led housing I may
be aware of things in the past and I'm
not so clear of things in the future so
on that one Madam chairman I've decided
that I will leave the chamber I think
and Mr quilts wasn't available today so
that's what I feel more comfortable
doing on a gender item 14 thank you okay
thank you thank you councilor Channel
anybody else oh councilor shauncey
um yes thank you Jim I haven't got the
right page but councilor Channel
mentioning
um you know um housing associations Etc
I am a trustee of Malden Housing
Association so perhaps I should
mention that thank you yeah thank you
well I mean and if any of you feel that
you need to leave the meeting if
something comes up you're not happy with
you you can either leave the meeting or
or just withdraw from the debate anyway
so that's absolutely fine okay thank you
members
um okay
um agenda item five which is public
participation I don't think we have any
do we burner no John okay thank you very
much okay right so moving on to General
items and the first agenda item is
agenda item six
um to report on the council's investment
activity for the financial year of 2122
in accordance with the chartered
Institute of Public Finance and
accountancy treasury management code
sectors TM code and the council's
treasury management policy and treasury
management practices there is a
recommendation that members review the
treasury out turn report for compliance
purposes officer Mr Leslie to present
the report and do I have somebody to
second that we
um note this with her note this report
before we go ahead with the report and
the discussion thank you Council
Thompson okay right over to Mr Leslie
okay the report looks back at the
treasury management performance for last
year uh the table on page 16 at
paragraph
3.7.3 details the type of Investments
held and amounts at year end
there was a higher balance invested than
usual at that point
um due in part to government money from
covid initiatives that were in the
process of being distributed
uh the council's long-term Investments
provided the highest returns through
that period and contributed to the
higher than budgeted income the returns
from different investment types are on
page 18 paragraph
3.8 to 0.1
the Prudential indicators were complied
with and
um are at appendix 2 with further
details with an exception around the
council's current account
investment limits for banks are two
million pounds or were at the time
however due to the nature of uh current
accounts in that it is not a fixed
investment like the others for example
if Government deposits a large covid
Grant payment there are occasions when
the limit was exceeded this was
highlighted to members previously and
the approved changes as a result of that
are detailed on page 19
paragraph
3.9.2 when that was bought to two
members previously
um this will help to assist manage that
I still recommend a limit is put on the
current account despite its nature to
help ensure good management of cash
appendix 2 also shows the council has no
Capital borrowing
okay are there any other officers who
wish to comment
nope in that case this uh has oh no
before I go to members if there's any
officers wanted to add anything but no
that's good thank you um Mr Leslie um
right councilor Thompson's already
um seconded this so now I'd like to open
the floor for members for Thursday okay
Clinton answer fluka chairman I'm sorry
sorry that I was late and if anyone
noticed I also apologize for being
inappropriately addressed when I came in
the chamber
um
I'll let you work it out
um
um just a couple three points that I'd
like to bring up with the 151 officer
um
a pagar 3.7.3
um
I've looked back some of the previous
agenda items that have covered this off
over the previous years and and they've
no although I presume we've had deposits
with local authorities they were never
actually specifically mentioned so I see
that that's in there
um I think everybody's aware that we do
have uh two million pounds on deposit or
loan to sarik and we I think we all know
where what the position is with dark and
I'm I'm grateful for some of the
comments that I've received from Essex
County Council regarding that position
and I think we should all take a huge
amount of comfort in the email that the
leader sent out where she assured us
that the money was going to be repaid on
the 22nd and I I look forward to having
that confirmed but I wonder if
um the 151 officer could confirm what
other local authorities we're currently
loaning to money to and perhaps that's a
fairly quick answer I guess and then I'd
like to go to paragraph three points
3.7.6
um yeah this is a great return on this
five million pounds and I I just
wondered whether or not and we've
actually drawn down any profits on that
or whether or not the 177 is actually
sitting with the 5 million and finally
chairman we've had conversations about
this before in the past 3.9.1
um can I can I commend the 151 officer
and his team for
um the reactionary times we're dealing
with these matters because I think
that's very very good thank you all
right before I hand over to Mr Leslie
I'd just like to say that it has been
reported in the press that thorough
Council have just received 850 million
pounds funding to cover the debts that
they owe
um so if the Press is to believe that's
that's all good to go but okay Mr
Leslie's it's
3.7.3 first of all
3.7.3 yes uh list of the local
authorities
um happy to circulate
um that I assume that's the Lego
authorities as of now or is that the
year end
I think it'd be interesting to see both
actually I have both absolutely we can
do that we circulate that thank you very
much
um
3.7.6 the drawdown yet the investment
income that that always comes in the
capital amounts will will remain the
same or the amount we have invested it
will of course go up and down depending
on the capital value but we get the
interest
um paid in from that side of it
um and 3.9.1 um thank you for your
comments
okay and um councilor Channel thank you
very much uh Madam German Council Bluff
you could already mentioned one thing I
was going to I was going to mention
about thurrock I'm also aware about
other authorities and I have seen a list
but I think
um if the Leslie had just said that he
will uh be sending me on both lists
store members of this committee so
that's good and indeed I wanted to
adjust the Council of fluka and other
members decided send an email around and
I did check on Mr Leslie and Council
White's just highlighted what thorac
Cavanaugh got and we will get our money
repaid I have checked that out with Mr
Leslie
um regarding again the same errors that
Council frug has gone on to and I'm
looking at 3.9.1 now myself and I can
appreciate all the good work that's been
done to save if you like the same thing
happening again can I just ask though
and I do appreciate and the you drew
attention yourself Mr Leslie to 3.9.2 to
reduce the recurrency of these breaches
and what the team have done and great
work I'm assuming that that we do know
that that's working well that the action
that has been taken obviously from what
you said and um obviously
um it's part of the system then that
failed I would think all the process
within the system that led to those
incidences occurring in the first place
I can't recollect or said previously
when you said this had been highlighted
to committee but really it's just
seeking assurances that everything now
is working it should and we've had no
hiccups thank you
yeah thank you so obviously the reasons
and sort of action taken a detail within
that that table
in terms of the nature of the account uh
yes what the changes we've made will
certainly help um and I think the the
right ones to make and what I said is I
don't propose removing a limit for that
because I think that helps focuses and
produce targets and it will be reported
to members where it does go over that as
well
um so I think that that's absolutely
helped
um what I won't say is we won't see any
more going over because it's a current
account we can't guarantee what comes in
and out we don't have control it's not a
fixed term investment and it's a very
slightly unusual it's a current account
we're not putting money out for a fixed
amount we we don't necessarily have
control about what people pay into our
account particularly if government pay
large sums of Grant in there and from
that side but I think the fact that
we've got a limit and that we'll report
when that happens and the action taken
is very helpful around that I encourage
that
um I don't know if Mr porchis um perhaps
chair might come in and just confirm the
arrangements appreciating we can't
guarantee it won't occasionally go over
report is here
Ben is
well done good evening
members and officers yes I can confirm
with Mr Leslie what Mr Leslie has said
that increasing the limit
for the current account certainly has
helped to operate within those limits
although there are still very occasional
times when grant money and whatnot does
come in
uh that might exceed it but we'll see a
lower list than you see here for the
next uh six months
thank you thank you
um does anybody else oh uh councilor
Swain
um
chairman um C point 8.1 shows the
returns we get on certain investment
funds 2.48 3.58
um and obviously virtually nothing on
the money market funds
um but also somewhere I seem to remember
saying seeing that we got 16 return on
some particular Investments
um is the very low average due to having
to hold a lot in Money Market funds
because of these large amounts that come
in from government and have to go out at
short notice or is there any scope for
um putting some of the money market
funds into
more interest earning investment
so the low rates of return that you're
seeing in the in the shorter term
investments are actually just due to the
um position of the interest rate at the
time obviously back then it was you know
0.1 so you put money in the bank you're
not going to get anything what we
obviously balance is uh the risk and
return so I don't believe we're
receiving 16 on on that anything in that
side
um we've gone for low risk
um Investments such as the money market
funds um so they're spread portfolio so
it's not that um
we would have to have a change in
investment policy I think to start
um investing in perhaps more high level
returns where we are investing perhaps
more in um in the share market Etc
around that so the low returns are
purely due to the interest rate that was
prevalent at the time
okay councilor stamp yeah thank you
madam chair I'm going to ask a really
silly question most probably and please
forgive me if everybody knows this but I
don't and where we've got the two
million Bank counterpart limit now is
that the banks limit or is that limit
that we've set and if it's the bank's
limit did we put ourselves at risk were
we insured when we went over that thank
you
that's our limit that we're set as part
of the treasury management strategy and
limits on that obviously that's part of
our risk management to ensure that we
don't have
um High exposure to certain areas so
therefore we manage the limit that we
place so within individual Banks we have
a limit of uh two million pounds um with
each
in German I'm
might just inquire at this point with Mr
Leslie all members should have received
an email regarding treasury Management
training and that is due to take place I
would very much hope so that members of
this committee have signed up to that
and other members too because that is
something that we should be doing as
counselors so I could just whilst Mr
Leslie I've at the moment are you
receiving quite a good sign up to that
training thank you
yeah thank you so the training uh takes
place on Monday evening uh foreign will
be uh delivered by our treasury
management advisors
uh in terms of that side of it uh we
have received a good number of
acceptances from various members at the
moment
um
probably about 10 just as a quick count
but obviously the more we can attract uh
the better Madam chairman I suggest
perhaps a reminder goes out to members I
think that might be helpful to say how
important is bearing in mind
um this report and other matters thank
you thank you okay Council of Luca
just on that one chairman there was a
time when we never used to have these
type of things on a Monday night because
they clash with Parish Council meetings
so um so I'll actually be at South
Minster
um from about 7 30 onwards so uh it's an
important meeting so I'm afraid it'll
have to be Sovereign to this but I just
hope that bear in mind less than a third
of members uh have said that they're
going that this will be available as a
recording afterwards
um yep we've got about 13 responses
hopefully go up and I will definitely
send a reminder in terms of the
recording unfortunately uh we're not
allowed to record that
um I will ask for any slides Etc from
our advisors as well but um they do not
allow that to be recorded
okay right
um now do I this report has been noted
to can we agree this by ascent
agreed okay well done members okay
moving on to agenda item seven which is
budgetary control report as at the 31st
July 22 the purpose of the report is to
provide the strategy and resources
committee with information in relation
to financial performance over the period
of April 21 to July 22 and that the
committee notes the forecasted 2223
financial position as at 31st July of
this financial year
um okay Mr Leslie over to you please
thank you so this report sets out the
council's forecast year-end budget
position the council continues to be
impact financially from the pandemic and
now from the cost of living crisis due
to ongoing covered pressures relating to
Refuge Leisure and tax collection rates
the budget was set with a 452 000 pound
contribution from the general fund
Reserve
in addition to this there were approved
uh there were excuse me sorry
there are approved budget increases of
229
000 pounds mainly relating to increased
resources in the planning service which
took current budget contributions from
the general fund uh from 552 000 to 681
000 pounds
mainly are due to higher than budgeted
inflationary pay increases and lower
Leisure income there is a forecast
service budget overspend this year
this has been offset to an extent by
increased income from recycling due to
commodity prices and tonnage collected
once improved tax collection rates and
investment income has been taken into
account the budget variance is 108
000 pounds overspend
this would reduce the general fund
balance from 5.8 million to 5 million
still above the minimum recommended
level of 2.6 million a revised
medium-term Financial strategy and
updates will be presented to the next
SNR meeting okay thank you Mr Leslie um
now it's recommended this report is
noted do I have a seconder please
Council Thompson
um right okay now this um item is now
open to for debates and members do you
have any questions councilor Swain uh
yes
um
uh the
drop in the fund General front of 0.8
million
um has qualifications that at the end of
year pluses and minuses that were might
um
would change that and does Mr Leslie
have any
um inkling as to whether the balance of
those is like to increase or decrease
that 800 000 Gap
thank you yes that there will be changes
as we go obviously this is a sort of a
mid-yearish Point
um now to the best of our knowledge as
things Trends you know transpire we'll
learn more and certainly things are
changing an awful lot at the moment
um so I'll get my crystal ball out and
say what's happening I think it's very
difficult at the moment I think there
are some pressures emerging and there's
some rather signs as well I mean
interest rates are increasing we've
obviously just had a report about uh
investment in investment returns and
that would obviously have an impact on
the amount of Investments but quite
Energy prices are going up and inflation
um is a factor so yes I I can pretty
much guarantee change I suppose
yes it was another unfair question I
think probably any other members
councilor Fluker
um um
the table in 4.2 I mean that says to me
that our original budget was 3.7 million
and now it's 14.3 million I'm sure I'm
reading that right
um so that's sort of is a variance of
579
um
presumably that was uh that was at the
financial position at the 31st of July
so
um
I just wonder what the financial
position was now and I I appreciate the
need for crystal ball
but I think there's a lot of things that
we we know about based on what's been
said at the finance working group so I'd
be interested to know what you're
actually forecasting and I know it's
difficult for for year end and what you
think the position is exactly now thank
you
so the um table there table two for
parallel 4.2 um it's got the revenue
commitments that's the 350 000 pounds
that you see there what happened at the
end of the year
um there was 350 000 pound put into a
revenue commitments Reserve
um that Reserve is for where there are
still commitments
um but we can't foreign accounting
reasons put them in the balance sheet
and recognize them so for example if a
project has started which had approved
funding but we hadn't been able to spend
all the money within the year then that
goes into the commitment reserve and
Carries forward so what we're seeing
with the 350 is yes the budget has
increased your right to 14.3 million but
350 of that is due to uh Reserve
commitments which were put in last year
to offset uh expenditure for this
current year due to where projects uh
were in motion or expenditure was
um delayed so that's not a impact on on
the bottom line or recurring item around
that in terms of the estimates you know
the finance working group side of it it
was similar to this and certainly based
on these figures coming forward
we've obviously doing some more work
where we are doing some more work is
around their Leisure forecasting which I
think is still continuing to be around
about the position reported but that's
going to be a major factor I've
mentioned uh interest rates as well and
that's obviously changing a lot almost
day by day so hopefully we'll receive
some better news around our interest
rates income from that and we're
marching on a very regular basis as well
it is our largest area but the refuse
budgets around that as well so commodity
prices and sensitivity around that they
are some of our biggest areas the pay
inflation still to be approved but we
have one Union has accepted and two are
now out to vote on that with their
members and so have to wait and see how
that changed but that's obviously a big
variance and of course we will continue
to update as change is coming
cancel if you can come back yeah thanks
I'd just come back briefly on that
because
um you know I looked at the the figures
that were reported to the working group
and I appreciate they are very much
draft but they did seem to be a long
long way away from what you're you've
put here and I appreciate that this was
this is based on what happened in July
um so I'll refer back to those and and
hopefully when that group meets again we
might understand better what the true
position is of this chaos in relation to
what I call an overspend or we've
exceeded our budget buyer and and
chairman just to change very very
quickly and I'm I'm on page
um 32 and 5.2 in particular members
allowances
um I wonder what was included in members
allowances because if we just took the
basic allowance the basic allowance
which is roughly I think I think someone
said they're four or five thousand quid
I don't know but if we take the upper
limit five thousand that's 155
000 for for 31 members and we've not had
31 members all the time so I I just
really wondered where we got this
244th on
um
what's in member I think what I'm asking
is what's actually in the members
allowance budget heading because a
member's allowance is exactly that it's
not expenses it's not
um it's not the money paid to the leader
or the chairman as a fund that's a
completely different thing all together
so the members allowance obviously
that's the basic members allowance and
also the special responsibility
allowance that comes in there
um side of it
and there's also a affected in a
forecast of a four percent increase in
Mendes allowance
um as well
due to the um
inflationary rise that occurs with
members allowance each year which is um
forecast but to be confirmed at the
moment
I just I don't understand the figure so
if we you know if we put in
um you know I think I think the chairman
of the Committees get an extra allowance
so that's another 15 grand and I suppose
there's one for the the
um the chairman and then the leader gets
a multiple I think of about two point
something or other but that's still
quite a lot short of you know if we add
it all together it's still a little bit
short so you know perhaps you drill into
it and let us know by email yeah yeah
thanks cheers
thank you um counselor Channel
thank you madam chairman
um it is on that subject actually
um I'm aware that the independent panel
we have an independent panel
historically that's required to meet and
I'm aware that independent panel did
meet recently in fact I think all
members were approached and asking about
various questions to do with various
elements to help inform the panel or
whatever else they work they do well can
I just be informed Madam chairman what
the route is now for that um sort of
exercise having been completed and
perhaps where members can be aware of
the outcomes of that because normally I
think it is reported and recommendations
come forward so I wonder if Mr Leslie
could perhaps just give some information
regarding that that might be helpful
next thank you uh there's a report going
to Council in November which should
outline all those points and take to
members for a decision around allowances
going forward
absolutely okay do we have any other
questions
nope okay well thank you everybody
um I'd like to
um call that the vote be noted can we
agree by a cent yeah excellent okay
thank you very much right moving on we
have got agenda item eight which is fees
and charges policies for 23 and 24. the
purpose the report is to review the fees
and charges policies that have been put
forward by officers price the approval
of the 23-24 budget an updated
medium-term Financial strategy
the detailed schedule of fees and
charges will be reviewed based on the
policy decisions and the committee will
recommend the actual 2324 fees and
charges to council during the next cycle
of meetings the 23-24 income budgets
will be based on the recommended policy
and there's a recommendation to the
council that the
2023-24 fees and charge charges policies
appendix a be approved
um so over to Mr Leslie again
okay see you all night tonight Chris
thank you Jim uh the fees and changes
policy sets out the direction of travel
for preparing the detailed fees and
charges list which will come to members
for approval and ultimately sets what
the charges uh will be
the table on page 36 at paragraph 3.3
sets out the proposed changes to last
year's policy
okay right it's um recommended that this
report is agreed do I have a seconder
yeah councilor Durham okay members this
report is now open for debates so who'd
like to start me off
or does everybody agree them as our as
is ah Council Legend
just sneaked in
I was thinking that was the first time
ever we had no questions on report okay
cancel 11. there's a few things there's
actually a few of this this time some
questions and uh also some
um thoughts that members may take in
before Carl Blanche agree in this the
first one is on off street car parking
it's on page 37 in the table
um I'm concerned where the
recommendation is remove free parking on
bank holidays
the concern is is we're trying to
stimulate people to attend towns and
recreational facilities free parking can
actually help and I'm sure that's not
going to generate thousands upon
thousands upon thousands of pounds so I
have a concern that removing that puts
more financial pressure on on residents
attending
um the second one is modern Promenade
Car Parking and the bit that it says aim
for overall the addition is um aimed for
maximum cost recovery for Promenade park
with car parking being a key contributor
that's going to be can someone explain
what what maximum cost recovery and
where the Gap is and that that that
projected
um is going to be made made up by um
doing that
uh should I just go for it I've only got
a couple more the only small bits so
um the other one is down on a service
David page 38 it talks about commercial
team Commercial Services box office
um and it says in the comment card box
there it says and this is just for my
information the register of a strategy
in conjunction with the chairman of
community services committee I'm I'm
reminisce I don't know who that is
that's this committee is it used to be
CS okay so we probably want to change
that because I've spent a lot of my life
um and and finally which you would very
much expect
um River warfage
um I thought that when we discussed this
last year that it was going to be
um a a CPI inflation rate for the next
two years and then it will be reviewed
rather than what this recommendation is
is over three years removing the
concession fully
so I'll stop there but I would like to
request come back in a second if I may I
thought we agreed that committee
hmm
yeah
please thank you Chris thank you thank
you so um car parking maximum cost
recovery so I think it's taking into
account that actually
um
we need to ensure that all the costs for
the area are covered in terms of
actually what that means in terms of
detailed fees and charges uh coming
through that will be part of the report
that that comes in
um to members the next so I can see what
they actually uplift proposed are I
think the the strategy the policy is
that actually it does do that cost
recovery side of it around those
principles and that that's really what
it's it's saying appreciating that
there's um other aspects at play
um in terms of the uh box office uh one
the committee yes thank you I thought we
had changed that but thank you for
spotting all that because it actually
hasn't changed it and in terms of the
wolfidge side of it um that's obviously
something that can be considered by uh
members at committee when they set it
each year I think
um
may be corrected but I think the
intention was it was coming back
um with the concessions to phase it out
um in future but obviously it's a member
decision which um like can make um each
each year around that
just may thank you firstly the costs I
will certainly won't support that uh
cost increasing without the details so
I'd suggest that that gets deferred
because how can we look at what that
that makeup of costs actually is until
we know what that shortfall is and how
that's calculated to suit that um how
much is the car parking on the prom per
day for a full day's charge at the
moment
no I know that I know that and then I've
deliberately asked that question
um I don't know it's with the detailed
list of fees and charges and that may be
where um the question
is eight and a half quick so it's eight
pound fifty and again if we're going to
do stuff like that we I think we need to
look created creatively about things
like this without car parking charges
for our assets and I've I've said this
several times that why don't we look at
an opportunity of actually increasing
that cost
but have a discount card like a Malden
card for modern residents who use the
modern facilities and then the Burnham
if you want to go down that route they
give us a South Minster too yeah any
anywhere you like you know
um where people come the the jewel in
the crown is more than for tourism isn't
it
um so you you know I think we rather
well it is you've all got lovely
Villages and I love the villages but
people come to the town you know I I
have to as chairman I have to jump in
and say I'm very sorry but molden
District as a whole is a duel in the
crown not only are there six but of the
whole country anyway we're talking a
fees in charge of yourself I'm just
trying to make a point and I know that
um
I think we need to look creatively at
that
I don't think we should just go you know
we we look at up in the charges so I
think we why can't we do more is my
opinion but there's maybe an opportunity
to generate more Revenue so that's
that's the key thing and I'm with
warfage uh I'd like that to be deferred
because
we know the challenges that the the
barge owners have and what what really
interested me was the current policy the
commentary that was in there set fees to
complete with alternative birthing
facilities on the East Coast there are
none the only thing is mistly which
doesn't take commercial vehicles anymore
um so we have none so we we are unique
in that respect so I think what we've
done is looked at supporting them which
I think the owners and the people who
run their business have been very
grateful for in in very turbulent times
um so I I would say that this gets
amended the proposed concession amended
to the next two years that we apply uh
inflate array of inflation the increase
to those warfish charges because
inflation has gone up and they should
pay and they want to pay and I think
that's what we agreed and that's what
went to full Council last time
um yeah I think I'll leave it there
uh right thank you now uh Mr lizard's
answer is the part of it but we have
just discussed that and as we both
thought the detail comes back at the
next meeting and we discussed the detail
this is just the the principle of
charges then we dribble down into detail
of what detail goes into any changes to
the fees at the next meeting but I'll
get Mr Leslie to explain a little bit
sorry you can't vote on that then you
you cannot because it's it's rather the
wrong way around you should have the
detail which have informed the decision
to be able to say yay or nay and have an
options paper
so what the policy sets out is the
Strategic direction of travel from the
principle around the car park being
actually its cost recovery side of it I
think you raise some very good points
about actually how do we Implement that
uh policy that strategy about cost
recovery you've listed a number of
options and that's where it come back
and say actually based on that principle
here's what we're proposing to do and
then they can be voted on in terms of
the detailed side of it I think at the
moment it's the high level direction do
we want that
where we're looking to do cost recovery
and then it's okay so how do we go about
doing that and I think that is why this
is coming first and then the detail
rather than the other way around so
there'll be an opportunity to do that
with the detail side of it
I understand the concept of that but I
don't feel comfortable and voting for
something that I don't have because at
the moment if I say that I'm going yes
we're going to look for maximum recovery
yeah so this is this is only a proposal
um right counselor fluka
you know
I'm on right oh yes that light turns on
so
um
I think my overarching comment about
this is and you know I I just want to
mention this working group again because
we are looking at fees and charges in in
a massive amount of depth and we're
drilling into all sorts of things and
there's been talk about whether things
should be brought forward I mean I'm
beginning to think now that we seem to
be out completely out of sequence with
how we're moving with working groups
with with committee meetings and Council
you know there's so much more is going
on in that working group which you know
I know we're all tired for time but you
know it would have been
so much better if we'd had some of that
stuff reported here tonight under PNC so
that we could you know discuss it and a
lot of it impacts on what councilman
says you know and I think a lot of it
would probably answer his questions
um
you know I'm almost saying and I know
you you hate the word but I mean it's
almost as though we should have another
meeting at this Committee just to go
through what the working group are
talking about so that we really can give
the officers some kind of a a steer I
think that's really important
um I think as far as
um parking's concerned I mean it's
really really difficult to get parking
spaces at Malden at certain times of the
day so I always think that if we're over
subscribed as room for movement I
understand the arguments for the the
bank holidays but we've known before and
we have done the work that when you
offer free parking in Morden Town Center
car Parks invariably all that happens is
is local residents take advantage of it
and and to give weight to that argument
you've only got to look in the car park
tonight because when I arrived I thought
I saw those cars and I thought I bet I
know what this is all about football
it's not you know I thought there's
going to be a huge amount of people here
tonight the car parts packed and know
you look you know the warfage thing is a
difficult one but you know I think
you know basting my thoughts around what
you said about the Promenade Park
parking costs I think we need to bring
forward the information about how much
we're spending on the wharf at the
moment I know it's I know we can look at
comparable costs and everything else I
mean all businesses are under pressure I
mean you know we've just started to
release that pressure as we've gone into
a lot more pressure so we appreciate
that I don't think it it would be a good
idea to link it to inflation because I
think my dear friend member from Malden
May well end up getting kill hauled over
the next two years because I think you
know we're potentially at 10 this year
and 12 the next year
um I I do in the back of my mind
do sort of remember something about an
index linking but you know but we we
really mustn't positively discriminate
against businesses you know everybody is
under pressure
um you know I know the you know the
historic importance but we've got to be
very very careful of
you know just identify certain
businesses and support them but I think
it's it's a hard recommendation to
accept although I think the principles
of it I do but maybe
um chairman do you mind if I call you
chairman by the way oh you've been
you're in America at the time don't you
remember interesting anyway I'm sure
after all these years councilor white
you're happy for me to refer you to as
universally any way you like
so anyway Jim so I mean it might be an
idea just so that we can get this to
council is to say that you know we agree
in principles subject to the officers
providing the background information on
these particular
errors and then we can debate it at
Council
um you know I feel that that would be
supported in the round thing yeah and if
I come to your Council Channel I would
say that I'd like to thank councilor
Swain for taking over the running of the
um working Finance group but I do think
that if we can organize it that an
in-person meeting to go through in depth
might actually work well but obviously
this depends on officers time but I
think if we can organize it I'd
certainly like to see another meeting
where we could drill down on the warfage
I don't want discrimination anyway
positive or or negative that's something
we can't do we have to be impartial and
I would like to see if we can organize
this obviously it's going to take quite
a lot of work because I think sometimes
you can get more achieved an in-person
meeting
um but obviously it's down to directors
in their time but that's something I'd
like to see going ahead
um right counselor Channel
yeah or hybrid yeah whatever we can do
but obviously it's it's officers yeah
yeah thank you madam chairman I think at
the beginning you said chairman actually
with the chairman of the committee so
perhaps I should just say chairman
um regarding the matter we're talking
about and the recommendation is that
this has to go to council anyway so I
just asked a question because it did
come up at the working group Council of
fluke is referring to about we felt all
the uh detail from that discussion she
had actually been presented to all
members and that's an opportunity there
or are we saying that we need now
another round of meetings as well before
we get to the point where we can talk
about the income Etc this is the policy
area and I you know from last year we
did the same there's something in the
back of my mind and I'm not sure if it
was the war fridge but I thought we did
agree
to have a meeting with the barge owners
over something and I'm sure that came
into the round of meetings and I can't
remember if it was explicitly or just on
the warfage there was certainly
somewhere where I think there was
something so there ought to be some
dialogue with the bio no just directly I
think the thing is with kovid this was
all quite a long time ago so if members
would indulge me I'd like to go back to
offices and see see what we can organize
before either the next Council or the
next strategy a result it was last year
yeah so we can move forward I'm
councilor Lagan I just said Thank You
chair I know I know this is difficult
thing but it's the meetings have
actually taken place and conversations
have spoken with them right and that's
great but my and I don't mind being
killed I'm strange like that
um but yeah but when when you get two
hours of time didn't you so you know
it's a lot of money for two hours at
window but um what the point I'm trying
to make is we we had a decision last
year where we said we would do and
whatever inflation is that's that's the
risk
so inflation being 10 at the moment if
it goes up by 10 next year and it goes
up by 12 the year after that's what that
was what basically was agreed by the
committee to go forward so this is a
change in the proposed concession and I
don't feel that this is the right thing
to do I think we should say you know if
the others are we're going to get the
detail on fine with that but with this
one the the the you talk about bringing
tourists in we know that people bring
tourists in actually Council Durham came
on a barge once when I was hiring it
with a person from America to show them
around
so I think we need to be really careful
and actually say within this paper which
most of it I'm quite comfortable with
because I understand fees and charges
I'm not naive but I think because of the
unique nature you know it's like
charging the crows at the terror of
London a tenor each to be there you know
let's let's support where we can in an
ethical way the businesses and the
Charities that operate down there
currently and then the increase is
happening the increase will happen but
that gives them the foresight to be able
to gear their business plans to be able
to survive
that's what you were talking about with
some of these things and use the
facility which actually is tying up
against a brick a concrete face and plug
it into Power which they pay for anyway
so I think I would I would support
support most of this but I would like to
have the warfage taken out and looked at
separately and I'd also like the wolf is
to go back into inflationary increases
over the next two years and then be
looked at again in detail yeah thank you
excellent well I mean as chair I don't
think we can take this out and I've Got
a Feeling something was hit there but I
would like you to trust me that we will
look into this and come back to you
um you know with exactly what was in the
minutes I know you probably recall
better than I do to be fair but we must
be really careful that we do not
discriminate because there's going to be
so many businesses I mean pubs
restaurants we cannot if we are going to
offer one thing for one business
we are going to have to offer it to all
businesses so we have to be really
really mindful I mean I I really support
the barges I love seeing the barges um
you know I've seen them since I was a
child
um but but I think we should leave it in
there with the caveat that we go back
and we check exactly what was described
and make sure that it's exactly right
before it comes back to the next meeting
and then if we don't discuss it in a
separate budget working group or Finance
working group that we do discuss it at
the next full Council or the next SNR to
drill down on on what we're going to um
put in there
um counselor Channel
thank you madam chairman it's not to do
with this item so can I ask a question
on something else thank you yeah it's
just out of interest and I appreciate
this is probably going to be where we're
just doing the policy setting and the
income but regarding and this is on page
30 and it's car parking events and I
have no problem it's just a mind of
change from what I can see where we're
changing head of paid service
um to be the director of Service
delivery but can I just ask my memory
needs a bit of refreshing because it
does say it's done a set fee for
specific events and that's dependent on
entrance fees and other things can I is
there a formula for that um or how do we
work that out because I find that quite
interesting because how do we project
the numbers of people or cars or you
know vehicles that might be required how
do we assess the size of events I mean
I'd be interested to have background
information on that um I'm not saying
that's really to committee but I just
would like to know how well that's
working
um bearing in mind it's been a policy
and all we're doing is that minor change
thank you
it's Leslie or Mr Holmes
thank you chairman um I don't actually
think we've implemented that I think
it's a contingency to allow us to do
that um there'll be a number of
circumstances around an individual event
which may suggest it's better to have a
single figure and so it gives us the
option to do it um but it would be based
on an event by event basis to decide you
know in terms of know what an average
income would look like let's say on a
weekend in the summer versus an event so
that that's all part of that calculation
but it's it's um it's a contingency at
the moment
okay
oh cancel the Swain and then cancel the
stamp Council Swain
yes thank you um
firstly on the
um
the warfage
um there is a statement in the following
table about the policy
um being
um to um which is to say look at the
alternative charges as a comparator
um uh the question is of course whether
there are any near comparators but to
call
um
rescinding the concessions of policy I
think is a misnomer
um we don't really have a proper policy
towards the barges
um simply looking at Watford charges and
so on isn't really the whole
um it isn't really a policy adequate
policy towards the barges
um I mean for instance I think in some
senses
um the wolfridge is analogous to
business rates for other businesses
um
as far as so I think the whole question
of developing a policy towards the
barges is something quite separate which
we don't have really
um all we have is a state board
statement and the policy sheet about
comparing it with other even that is
only really part of a policy it's not
adequate in itself as a thing
um as far as car parking is concerned in
the
um on Park and I see a bit of a
confusion here I'm not when you talk
about maximum cost recovery I'm not sure
whether that's
covering the cost of parking having
parking in the park
um I had always thought that car parking
charges were almost supposed to cover
the costs of the park
um in total and even produce some net
revenue
um that doesn't seem to be seems to be
what the policy what this document says
but um you know if if that is an
intention that um it is actually the
charges not just in the car parking but
overall
um cover the costs and contribute to our
resources that that's fine but so when
it talks about maximum cost recovery we
want more than that really and we're
talking about the park aren't we not
just the cost of the car parking
um
the other point
um
if I I think this probably links with
what council Fluker was mentioning
um the workings of the finance working
group that you refer to
um seemed to be um rather
unfruitful as we say
um maybe what
um but
um I think the reason for it
um the twofold
um
when is the the there is a different
there's a variation in Attitude to this
question of using Reserves
uh to fill up Revenue deficits
um and um actually some of us think it's
a serious thing Patrick German I think
we're throwing it and others take much
more relaxation counselors that's one
reason why I think
these These are these are really good um
comments and but that we need to move on
with your gender a little bit because
time is it that comes back to councilman
fluke's point about the sort of things
we that discussed at the working group
really need to come forward but this
committee exactly well that's what I'm
going to try and organize behind but
thank you for your comments I'm sorry to
shut you a bit Tim shorts right um
counselor stamp uh thank you madam chair
um I actually um I'm not prepared to
vote for
um the recommendation because it does
say charges policies at appendix a to be
approved
um I'm looking at the proposed policies
and I don't think there is enough meat
on the bones or drilling down or the
information to make a informed choice on
those um policies that are being changed
Council fluke has raised in
working groups and I don't think this is
a private confidential at all that a
parking strategy or a change in the
parking could be addressed which then
might actually alleviate some of these
shoes on here anyway and
um and I certainly won't be
um I don't agree with changing the
parking rules for disabled people or
whatever or on bank holidays
um I don't so I don't mean disabled
people but I'm sure it may come
eventually but on bank holidays
um because I don't think we've got
enough information to back it up so
Madam chair I'm afraid I won't be voting
I won't be agreeing with this
recommendation okay thank you and
councilor fluka
chairman I'm I'm getting concerned that
in theory I think if we don't agree this
recommendation to put this before
Council it goes nowhere yeah exactly
this means you have a huge problem with
your budget
um I think the important thing really is
to note that if we if we agree to the
proposal but with all of the caveats
that we've just said then that will
allow Council to spend a couple of hours
debating this absolutely the alternative
is we wait we wait until the next
meeting of this committee get all the
information then it goes to council and
unfortunately that clock is ticking down
um and you know I think you know that's
what I would propose which is basically
what I said before that yes we agree the
recommendation but subject to full and
concise information being presented to
council
yeah I agree and that was entirely uh
councilor fluke which throws suggesting
that we do between now and full Council
um so right I'm going to this uh to the
vote um can we have it's just one thing
I I I'm very disappointed and because
some because we have to rush something
through that's not detailed he's not the
right way of doing it but we're only
we're only talking a couple of items on
the agenda
um the the record the recommendation if
we take if we take the process as the
Constitution says that we have a
recommendation there and we take that as
as set it it says the charges policy
appendix they'd be approved if we
approve that policy with that there
we're approving what's in black and
white in appendix a and like counts the
stem you we shouldn't do that because
we've asked too many questions now
of the issues that are there or just
quickly uh councilor um Thompson and
councilor Chandler so councilor Thompson
first yes thank you very much chairman
um
yeah I have to take the contrary view
I'm more with councilor Fluker I have to
say because this is a wreck to council
and no matter what we decide our Rector
Council should be
Council has every right I so undoubtedly
will exactly rearrange it yes and make
new decisions so I think no matter
how many times we go back to this and
whatever we decide yes council is
Sovereign and Council will make the
decision so yeah I'm with councilor but
I think I'd ask for all the caveats to
be noted absolutely yes then we have
something to put to council with more
information with more information and
they can agree or not so on that basis I
am happy to support this recommendation
even though I might have reservations
about some of it okay thank you and just
quickly counselor Chana thank you
councilor Thompson's more or less said
what I was going to come from Madam
chairman and you did actually say you
asked earlier
um four members to trust you on this and
what you're going to do and I do Madam
chairman thank you thank you very much
so if we could have a show of hands
please because obviously we have a
recording vote please
um yeah we can have a recorded vote um
Berner could you do a recording do you
have a second though
we're working on the recommendations as
they stand with the caveat that we will
either convene a meeting or get more
information before it goes to council
um to drill down on the issues that have
been raised with the warfage and the
parking
sorry burner we can't hear you
perfect
with the addition from councilman blue
grow that full and concise information
is provided to council yes can we
confirm has that been seconded please
has that been seconded Council Durham
has seconded it
um I'm sorry it doesn't say what oh
well the report will be going to a to a
council these items will go to council
but what we're saying is the items that
you have the concerns over which is
parking and warfage we will have either
interim meeting or a lot more
information and drilling down before
it's actually
um shown at full Council
okay burner could we add that in that
we'll have a
yeah moment so I think it's probably
best if I withdraw my proposal chairman
and we go with yours thank you okay
right
proposal itself um I'm just going to try
and simplify it okay
um we did not meet um General approval
if we added to the end of the
recommendation we approved for
consideration by Council absolutely yes
so if it's if we um I'd like to amend
this to the report
um is agreed and goes to council with
further information and drilling down on
um some of the issues that we've raised
in relation to warfage and parking is
everybody
um agree that those terms are correct
and incented by councilor Durham okay we
could all vote on that please uh those
in favor I've asked for recalls oh sorry
recorded vote okay Berner can we do a
recorded vote please yes
cancel stamp
thank you very much okay members I will
call your name to an alphabetical order
um
can you please stand clearly for again
throughout Spain
councilor passenger four
Council China four
four
Council against
Council Shaughnessy
four
that's the stamp
against
Council Swain four
Pastor Thompson four
Council white four
that's eight four proposal two against
no abstentions okay thank you very much
burner okay thank you members and we're
now moving on to agendum I agenda item
nine which is supplementary estimates
environments procurement exemptions and
use of reserves first of June the 31st
July 22. the purpose of the report is to
report romance and supplementary
estimates agreed under delegated powers
while they are below the levels
requiring approval by the structure
resources committee and seek approval
where they are above the levels
requiring approval by this committee 1.2
to inform the committee of procurement
exemptions that have been granted in the
period and 1.3 to report on the use of
reserves During the period we've got
some recommendations recommendation
little one that the environments is
detailed in paragraph 3.3.1 be noted
that little two that the supplementary
estimate is held in paragraph 3.4.1 be
noted and little three that the
procurement exemptions as detailed in
paragraph
3.5.1 be noted and this is to report is
to be given by Mr Leslie yet again so
Chris it's your show again so over to
you okay so this is a regular report
required by the financial regulations
with all items for noting there were
environments between the resources
directorate and Service delivery for
repairs and maintenance items there was
one supplementary estimate for health
and safety reasons and two procurement
exemptions this time
okay thank you um now this it's
recommended that this report is noted do
I have a seconder
councilor Fluker
um okay members this report is now open
for debate if anybody would like to
raise any questions counselor stamp and
then Council Lagan fluka yes
um we don't have reports anymore for
noting
apparently I'm just being told we're
missing its Financial
um and that is down for noting
um chairman that's not what that's not
what the Constitution says it says that
reports for noting do not go to
committee they are background papers now
we either play by the rules or we don't
but I would propose that rather than
upset Mr Leslie
um he presents his report but perhaps we
need to just visit that okay thank you
councilor fluke and we'll uh look into
that
taking names will I'll take questions
now and then we'll sort that for the
next meeting um right counselor stamp
chairman it's a comment really not for
noting uh 3.5.1
um it was raised at PG a that there was
a the felt that the U Fest and the queen
baton relay didn't have enough
um
publication I think publicity not the
publication publicity uh and um I think
as I found out today we have an Essex
Cabinet member who's into who's Deputy
Cabinet member for tourism so what I
would hope I think cancer Durham
yeah yeah so yeah it was said today at
the meeting
um so um I would actually ask that it
cost a lot of money
um could we make sure that that is
looked into next time to make sure with
Essex County Council or Council Durham
supports if you're still in the position
that we well no everybody gets promoted
um I didn't mean it like that
and Madam chair that we do actually
seriously make sure that these events
that are costing us a lot of money are
promoted everywhere within the district
thank you and it wasn't to dig at ucat
so don't at all it was about using your
strengths which was noted today at the
meeting thank you I have to say that it
was a really really good event and well
done for the officers members and public
who helped put it on but I was a bit
disappointed it wasn't better reported
in the Press
um but like Council Durham is it on this
item you've got a question or is it a
separate item we're not talking about
you Fest but it's a question okay well
if you look for if Council again I'll do
you have to cancel cancel I just have a
question
um not relating to this but for the next
part of the Year we're using a lot of
resources on the current avian flu which
is going growing like Topsy I'm just
wondering whether that is likely to have
an impact in the
the remainder of the year
thank you
chairman so far of involvement with
avian flu has been to support the
official
um
organizations that have the
responsibility for dealing with that so
it's more of being in staff times
there's been no physical cost so yes
there is a cost but it's actually staff
rather than um actually cash as such
okay Council Lagan
it's got push me button um there's just
a couple of things that I just wanted a
little bit of clarification on it's um
veeramids 3.3.1 5014310 it was about
moving money over for essential
consultancy work on the Blackwater
Leisure Center contract
um was that is that a contract that we
have with a consultancy or is that a
spot hire from consultants and did that
have different companies come forward to
support that and the second one is only
two was the cost center one two one
um additional budget required for a
central Legion and water assessment and
testing of 20 000 pound season to be an
extortionately large amount of money for
that service on this building
okay Mr Leslie
yeah so the work on the Leisure contract
I think that's probably the the key part
it's around the Leisure contract
obviously we've had various negotiations
um around that side of it and that's the
cost of this uh consultancy for our
support uh along that it's a very
expensive contract
um we're also coming up to a period
where we're looking to uh renew our
options as well around that so that's
more for our costs and our advice in
ensuring that we get the best deal and
understanding around what's happening um
with the covid and impacts around that
side of it so it's legit that's not
actually the question but the question I
understand that but it makes sense to
use organizations for that but it's is
it a consultancy that we we work with
continually have a contract with or is
it a spot hire con oh sorry apologies I
understand the question now yeah yes
it's a consultant we work with um
continually and helped us with the
original contract so there's a good
in-depth understanding of it all in the
complexities and within the industry of
colleges in terms of the Legionnaire
water it's for for all of our assets so
it's not just the office it's across
across the piece
um with that I believe there's a lot of
work to be done and undertaken um around
that side of it uh just to make sure
that we're compliant and catching up um
with any areas so it's across the whole
property portfolio and officers would
have gone out and followed the
procurement rules when um getting that
as well thank you
okay right
um
could we um
note that that they're sent
okay thank you members I'm like okay
moving on to agenda item 10 which is the
street naming a numbering policy the
purpose of the report is to review amend
if required and approve Malden District
councils local policy and do diligent
measures with regard to section 3.1 of
the street naming and numbering policy
naming streets After People attached as
appendix a to a 1.2 to approve the
adoption of the full Street naming and
numbering policy under recommendations
to the council little one that the
street naming and numbering policy
appendix a is approved little two that
are comprehensive accessible policy for
use by residence developers offices and
Council town and parish councilors is
agreed which demonstrates and clarifies
the criteria applied to current Street
naming and numbering decisions and
little three that the council agree on
the local policy for the use or not of
people's names including a due diligence
stage undertaken via board members on
the suitable use of any name submitted
by residence officers or councilors Ward
or perished prior to them being
submitted for wider consultation when
naming new streets
um so it is a recommended sorry Mr
Leslie is to report on this one I think
it's a summary for myself
um the report seeks to ensure a
comprehensive and accessible policy
around Street naming as outlined at
recommendation two the policy largely
follows a national requirements which
you can't deviate from however there is
some discretion around naming streets
after people on page 55 at paragraph 3.1
that's that's the key area to highlight
around discretion
um this is the process the council
follows and it's written down there
given the potential sensitivities and
obviously uh recent publicized uh
matters nationally and globally around
main changing Etc the council only allow
hours suggestions of surnames with local
significance to be considered it is
intended the new policy is helpful for
all those involved in the process
thank you councilor Fluker um right okay
members this is now open for debate
councilor stamp
uh yeah thank you madam chair who knew
that it was such a big policy of the
older you actually when you start to
read it's absolutely massive
um I'd like to uh well done for the
policy I'd like to propose or do some
sort of amendment whatever you your
guidance is that it it goes from 14 to
28 days to go to be able to go to parish
and Town Council meetings because
they're only held generally about once a
month and if you I mean I don't know
about everybody else but whenever I get
an email it says we need this back
within good and snows how many days to
to respond to it as a district council
and it doesn't always go to town and
Parish councils I'm not in agreement
that roads are named after people who
are alive and I would also um
foreign
I think we need a robust challenging
mechanism to say what what is
quantifiable of somebody's contributed
to the district what you may think
somebody's contrary to the district of
maybe not what I feel or my residents
feel or the residents feel so I think we
need to be a little bit more stringent
on that
um but other than that I think it's it's
it's absolutely fine thank you does
anybody else have any comments uh
councilor Lagan and then councilor
Channel yeah I just want to say that I
think the reports is a really good
policy and a really good report so
whoever put the report together well
done and thank you and Lagan lanes are
perfectly good names
okay councilor Channel and then
counselor fluka thank you very much I
may have missed it um Madam chairman so
I do apologize if I have but I I
recognize um you're not permitted to
charge for the service of Street naming
and numbering
um of the duty to provide this service
is not discretionary what about if it's
a house property name
um I recognize that you can you can't
take a number off you can have a name
which is an aliased and but you have to
use the number as well but do we charge
for that because I'm aware of other
authorities that actually when you do
want to apply a name to a property there
is a charge for that
Mr Leslie I'm pretty sure we have a
charge with Mr Leslie will uh I'm not
sure I saw it in the report I could have
missed it though right okay
ah Michelle Edgington could you get Mrs
edgington's got some answers relating to
the process
um could you assist please
good evening everybody good evening
yes
um
we do charge for the edition of names
um two properties
um the rules state that full Street
learning and numbering we cannot make a
profit
um for that service therefore what we do
is we recoup the administration costs
associated with processing our
application
thank you very much okay thank you very
much and um have we got any updates on
is there an issue if we extended it from
14 to 28 days would that be a problem
um I I don't believe that would be um a
problem
um but uh Mrs Islington may be able to
confirm whether that will be or not
Mr
said you've had a query would there be
an issue if we extended the consultation
period from 14 days to 28 days because
it is it could be quite contentious
yes I think
at
um I think in Germany is from the time
that we received the application so I
think we need to look at that to make
sure it does include time with the
parish councils yeah so leave over with
me definitely yeah okay okay thank you
um
yeah it's a great document I can't
remember what the last one looked like
but
um there's I'm sure there must have been
a lot of learning it involved uh
involved around the evolution of this
because I think that if you look at page
52
um little lie
um where there's a requirement to
consult with Ward counselors and he says
the parish town councils as well
um I mean we did have this uh classic
situation in South Minster when
regardless of us saying so we ended up
with two roads with the same name which
took a little bit of unraveling but we
did get there in the end and and I think
three E and F on page 53
um this is this is quite interesting
because in tillingham you've got
englefield close named after the
developer and of course in Burnham
you've got Harding's reach
um and I'm sure there's lots of other
ones so these have definitely slipped
through
um but chairman the great thing about
this is is the one of the finest pieces
of Highways is actually in my ward and
that's David fisherway which I made that
proposal David was the Fisher family old
friends of mine I've known David and
mold for a long long time gone the rest
of their souls uh and and David did a
huge amount I think he was a chairman he
hasn't got my glasses on I'm thinking
about 81 82 83 he was chairman of this
Council he was an Essex County Council
he did a huge amount of work
um around you know the farming community
and supporting people and and I made the
proposal that we named the the relief
Road after David because he was always
in favor of something and uh and it went
through and we're having the official
soon and this chairman
having had the suffrage of listening to
us debate this I'll make sure you're
invited thank you thank you very much
Lane
yes thank you referring to this little
paragraph a second paragraph under 3.1
um if uh councilor stamp was proposing
that that be omitted I would second it
names of those still living also it's on
page 55
I mean I I I mean I'm happy to hold a
vote on this but my concerns are if you
wanted to have a a King Charles Road or
something else that would preclude us
um so I'm I'm I'm not keen but I'm happy
to hold a vote if members want to hold a
vote on whether that be
um removed I personally would like to
see it remain but I'm happy to hold a
vote on it
and I've checked Clarity so what we're
doing I I propose that the people who
are living is not named after a street
yes
um
yeah I mean I think if we hold that
separately and then do the rest of the
Amendments afterwards
sorry
I'm sorry chairman I was muttering yeah
is there no statute about this is that I
mean I I don't know pubs after living
members of your family
ah no I don't think I don't think we
need to I think Mr Lizzy's just pointed
out
um I think this is already covered names
of those still living of the suggested
use of a full name should be avoided but
may be allowed in exceptional
circumstances so are you okay with the
amendment that we keep it as it is but
we allow an extended consultation period
of 14 to 28 days
Madam chair only if we know what the
exceptional circumstances are and the
criteria no I'm sorry I feel very that
would that would be so strongly about
something yeah I feel strongly about yes
that that would be on a case that would
be on a case-by-case I think that would
be on a case-by-case uh what is the
criteria and that would be a member's
decision that would be membership on
Case by case and it would have to be
very very exceptional as in for instance
King Charles or something but it
wouldn't be as a matter of
um as a matter of case so I think we'll
put it to the vote with that still in
that it it living names are allowed in
exceptional circumstances but also that
we add on that um that the consultation
period is extended to 28 days to allow
for the consultation between parish and
town councils
um so have you got that um burner Madam
chairman oh sorry for 28 days I think
the officer said to leave it with her
and go and have a look so camera we do
it on the um basis that agree with that
providing the office of fines there's no
complication or something okay Bernard
yeah is that can have you got that
burner
lovely
catch a stump no it's not on the
agreement of it I've made the proposal
that that is what it should be and I'm
not prepared to back down to say that if
it's not suitable it has to be good
reasons why it can't go to 28 days I
can't think of anything why it can't and
also I'm sorry I'd like it well why
can't you no no sorry I thought we were
going to extend it um and do it in a
time frame to make sure that all parish
is good in and we're going to go away
and put the time dates on it so
basically agree the um Proposal with the
um caveat that it goes away and we allow
enough time that it goes to parish and
town councils for full consultation
that's right within the 28 days but
that's not what my understanding what
can it might even be longer than 28 days
I don't know that's right the officers
are going to look into
yeah the officer said could you go away
and look at that I think she was in
agreement with a bit but she said at the
end leave it with her now what I'm
saying is I don't know all the rules or
whatever it might be something that
makes this difficult or it has to be
longer so um I I'll go with the 28 days
but subject to that being okay or could
be longer by this or what you said Madam
German yeah are you okay take the
I'm okay with that yeah but I'd like it
noted somewhere that I do not agree that
if somebody is alive that a street
should be named after them I'd like it
minuteed thank you so evening
exceptional circumstances
okay that's fine can we minute that
please burner
lovely okay sorry
yeah okay right if we if we could um
take this to the vote now that um we
agree the
um the the report
um with the caveat that we will look
into extending the time to make sure
that um parish and town councils have
time to go to full consultations and
that the minutes are as requested by
Council stamp are noted all those in
favor it can we do this by a cent
okay thank you members okay moving on to
a gendum item 11 which is the egg to
um to a green extension to the homeless
and housing strategy from 2018 to
2023 to 2018 and
2025. we've got two recommendations
um little one that recommendations of
the council's auditor BDO which
advocated for the council's homelessness
and housing strategy to be extended to
be noted and this will too the the
proposed amendment and two-year
extension to the homelessness and
housing strategy so that officers can
continue to deliver against the
objectives therein be agreed and is this
uh Mr Leslie a game nope who's doing
this one we've got a report chairman
Mrs weekly if you you could please give
your report
thank you chairman and good evening
members
the Mormon District Council draft
homelessness and housing strategy
2018-2023 was first drafted in 2018 and
contains a number of actions which are
essential ongoing functions as well as
actions yet to be delivered the actions
are set out in the strategy starting at
page 58 to 65.
the actions cover work done in
homelessness allocations private sector
Housing and Development
the purpose of the housing strategy is
to explain the current housing service
explain the context under which the
service is being delivered set out
departmental goals and set out the
actions required in order to achieve
those goals
the housing audit of 2021 recommended
that the strategy be extended to 2025 as
many of the actions still relevant to
their current housing context
housing service resources are not
focused on delivering an updated
strategy in 2023 if the existing
strategy is not extended resources would
need to be refocused which could result
in some disruption to daily and general
service
however failure to have an active
housing strategy would create a
disconnect between the corporate vision
and the work of the housing team causing
officers to work toward unagreed or
unexplained outcomes
the Malden District Council housing
strategy has had a minor amendment to
align the strategy with the current
corporate outcomes within the council's
corporate plan on page eight
that's it for this report so I'd like to
just note that we have Mr John swords
and Mr Damian Geller on the line if
there are any questions from Members
thank you lovely thank you Mrs Wheatley
and before we go any further I would
like to thank our housing officers
because we're really lucky to have Mr
Geller and Mr swords and although I
might bend their ears every now and
again they do a really good job and as
an authority
um we're really lucky to have them now
it's recommended this report is approved
or agreed do I have a seconder councilor
fluka
um okay members anybody have any
questions on this report
uh councilor stamp no no questions same
as you I think they do a fantastic job
and I think they deserve a special
mention because they are often behind
the scenes uh and uh same as you madam
chair thank you it's brilliant report
very long but brilliant yep thank you
very much and uh officers I hope that
you uh note the thanks that we give you
and um that item is agreed okay well do
we agree that by sent yes yes perfect
okay right moving on to thank you very
much officers moving on to agenda item
12 any other business items of business
that the chairman of the committee
decides are Urgent I have one urgent
item of business which is investment
zones this item is brought forward for
consideration as local authorities
leading on the expression of Interest
process are required to submit
Expressions by the 14th of October 2022
this will be dealt with under a gender
item 15 in the private and confidential
section of the meeting
um and this is an item that came later I
agreed for this to be a um last meeting
um right okay so now we are can I before
you move too can I say another item of
business that's that's urgent is that
councilor Lagoon ran the London marathon
and I think it would be only nice
congratulations I am I am impressed well
done it's very kind and I'll send you
all a just giving link
that contribute to pancreatic cancer
research yeah I'm surprised I'm
surprised you haven't already done that
and cancerous uh Channel well two things
now Madam chairman
um no
she did the mud race though I think it's
the mud race they've done the mud race
twice can it please be no two councilor
Stampy's laughing for him that's
hilarious if I did do the marathon uh
what I would say is it's come up in
strategy and resources but I do actually
think does the chairman of the council
know because I think that's probably
something that ought to be reported
absolutely yes I agree entirely I think
that's the the auditor but I did do the
mud race and I haven't done the marathon
I did actually
um do the London one for Malden oh no
not for Malden it was um a mind thing
that I did do around the city of London
once and that nearly killed me and I've
done also the British Art Foundation
yeah okay Madam Chen before we go on to
the private and confidential stuff which
I'm going to be leaving for the first
item a gender item 14. can I just
qualify regarding that and the previous
one the the homelessness and housing um
I believe the correct terminology is
other registerable interests having just
looked and checked something up here and
also to say councilor Boyce was going to
come along tonight but bearing in mind
he's associated with the same arms house
charity I am he felt he wouldn't because
he knew I was going to be leaving the
chamber so once you've called for that
private business I'll I'll leave the
James Madam chair okay thank you very
much okay so we now go on to uh gender
item
um 13 which is
um private confidential session so I
called it under Section 100a part 4 of
The Local Government Act 1972 the public
be excluded from the meeting for the
following items of business on the
grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph oh golly I
haven't got the paragraph numbers here
uh oh gosh three three
oh there we go three of part one
schedule 12 Aid the act and that this
satisfies the public interest test do I
have a second
councilor Thompson okay thank you I'll
now invite members to make any comments
on the report once we've been assured
that everything's turned off
thank you for any